a new year is upon us and with it a slew
of roster changes in the ever
illustrious world of counter-strike
carlos snagged baby simple liquid bagged
the most fabled of frenchies and clearly
believe in oc supremacy and csgo's
native son is officially phasing up
oh and those are just the changes that
have been announced
it is going to be a banger year for
counter-strike so let's start it off
right
[Music]
okay so like subscribe turn on
notifications because we got [ __ ] to
talk about like counter-strike's next
great superstar in the making
money now for those of you who aren't
familiar with this 16 year old op
divinity you're in luck because we did
an offbeat on him of course none of you
seem to want to watch it since
apparently you're not into
counter-strike simple and or cloning
three things which i think are pretty
cool just
watch it okay
i worked really hard on it long and the
short of it is that this kid is
basically the second coming of simple
he's blonde from the cis
he's a highly aggressive op player
played for navi's academy roster and is
all around one of the craziest
counter-strike talents we've seen in
years
the issue of course is that navi already
have a major slash grand slam winning
roster and suffice it to say if it ain't
broke you don't fix it they don't even
need to ask mom they already have simple
at home so naturally navi put their
little simple to be out on the open
market and after like a month and a half
of knowing
exactly where he would end up because of
rumors and reports it came as absolutely
no surprise whatsoever when it was
announced that carlos had snagged him
every day every single day day in day
out i wake up i go anywhere and i see
the message sign him signing signing
signing signing signing signing
every [ __ ] day [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
welcome monessi this [ __ ] yeah
needless to say the acquisition of
manasi could be game changing for g2
they dropped a ton of money on nico and
even with a haphazard roster came second
at the pgl major so it makes sense that
they would write yet another fat check
munici's buyout was reported to be
upwards of six hundred thousand dollars
by the way and put a young explosive sky
is the limit offered by niko's side oh
and according to a report by hltv that
was released today alexi b is slated to
replace nexa as g2's igl which
could be sick i guess
i don't know have to wait and see and
look i know people are setting up some
pretty insane expectations around this
kid but personally and this is just my
opinion
i think he's going to excel at the tier
one level right out of the gate i don't
think he's being overhyped not since
sumail have i seen a prodigy of this
caliber speaking of young explosive
sky's the limit counter-strikers
i guess don hachi can eat his heart out
because the 16x9 boy
has gone legit i said in my last one at
me at the beginning of december what a
lot of others were saying at the time
which is that
i thought that rops could make an
invaluable addition to facebook and lo
and behold that's where he ended up also
in case any of you didn't see it they
included footage of a 14 year old rops
talking way back in 2014 about how it
was his dream to join faze and it was
extremely adorable okay hello my teeth i
am roxanne this is my baseline uh
recruitment challenge response powered
by cheapo
why do i want to be a part of facebook
well the answer is pretty obvious
but base is the biggest team around this
and it's obviously everyone's stream to
be a part of it anyway who's to say how
good phaze will actually be but with
kerrigan brokey twists rops and rain
that's a scary [ __ ] lineup i'm
definitely not a very big fan of faze as
an org but i really hope those players
do well with an n a aim god on that team
and a 19 by 20 king
how can i not support them now the real
reason we are gathered on this holiest
of occasions
have you welcomed our lord and savior oc
into your life
because liquids sure have for all of you
woefully uninitiated cowards who've yet
to start believing in oc supremacy feast
your eyes on team liquid's newest north
american opera fresh off his impressive
stint with extra salt oc has long been
regarded as one of our region's best up
and coming talents for those of us
who've been watching him since the
singularity days and later with atk and
cloud9
it'll be really cool to see him finally
get his shot on a tier 1 roster of
course that's not the only liquid
signing that was announced as of late
although this next one did come as a
little bit less of a
shock
so
following several reports liquid finally
announced that they had added none other
than shock see jesus to their lineup is
it a weird pickup
kinda yeah i mean i don't think anyone
could have seen this coming is it good
sure shocks is far from washed and
definitely stands as one of the most
storied experienced veterans in the
whole of cs go i genuinely think he
could offer a lot to team liquid
especially since at least to me an
outsider it seems like their issues are
largely mental they've yet to announce
their fifth of course but as i said back
in december it has long
long been reported to be nitro and with
a fresh mix up and captain america back
at the helm
i genuinely think that this liquid
roster could do great things
sorry
copium went down the wrong hole
anyway obviously there is a ton more to
talk about with the frenchies and
astrology and whether stu and tim are
actually going to evil geniuses or the
latter is just baiting harder than hiko
in a valoran server but we'll talk about
that stuff when there's stuff to talk
about
it's gonna be a busy year let's not get
ahead of ourselves for now let's just
revel in the fact that 2022 is going to
be a banger year for counter-strike i
just
i got that feeling you know i think a
lot of other people do too with new
story lines emerging and all these
awesome roster mix-up esl's women's
circuit announcement
it's just
cs is going to kill it this year now
that you're all up to date with how it
started make sure you stick with us for
everything that this year has to offer
see you next time
speaking of young explosives sky is the
limit counter strikers
any 69ers in the chat
after four what's up
sorry i just said
just wanna it just sounds so much like
you're saying 69ers 69ers in the chat
69ers
okay
i even though i know you're saying 16
and niners
69. no i think i mean i think you're
right i think like 80 youtube comments
are just gonna be like it sounds like
he's like 69ers